I'm Richard Bacon.
Let's talk about surveillance.
But let's do it quietly because
they're probably listening.
That thing in your pocket
that you call a smartphone,
it's a tracking device that
just happens to make calls.
Digital tracking has become
a part of our everyday lives.
It is how we answer
our biggest questions.
When are those cute
shoes going on sale?
What happened to that cute
girl I knew in high school?
Where's that cute
commander of ISIS?
[laughter]
That's right.
The same technology
that targets terrorists
is also being used
to sell you Halloween
costumes for your dog.
You're probably
aware that companies
are collecting your data.
But you don't know
the half of it.
Let's run the numbers.
[applause]
1,500, that is how many pieces
of information data company
Acxiom has on every single
consumer in the United States,
1,500.
If you asked me for
10 interesting pieces
of information about
myself, I'd struggle.
Acxiom bundles your information
into profiles with catchy names
like "Men in Trouble," and
then sells them to advertisers.
"Men in Trouble"
is the file made up
of married men who've
recently searched
for flowers and chocolates.
[laughter]
In trouble.
91-- researches at the
University of Pennsylvania
found that when you look
up-- this is amazing.
When you look at
medical symptoms online,
91% of those websites
are sharing your searches
with third parties, even
shipping the information
directly to the same brokers
who monitor your credit scores.
In other words, everybody
knows about your weird rash.
300-- according
to a recent study,
it takes just 300 Facebook
likes for big data
to know you better
than your spouse.
The algorithms used by
Facebook are so good,
they can predict your
sexual preference
with up to 88% accuracy,
which means Mark Zuckerberg
knows you're gay before you do.
0-- that is the
amount of messages
that you have
deleted in your life.
There may be a Delete
button, but there's
no such thing as delete.
Apps track every
key that you push.
You can find anything you want
online except for privacy.
And those were the numbers.
[music playing]
[applause]